the ADCC is the Premier submission
grappling tournament in the world we
just had it a couple of weeks ago we saw
many demonstrations of greatness from
athletes you coached but a year ago
the team and you were at a very low
point
take me through that Journey what was
the lowest point we had a very very
tight team for many years which began in
New York City during the peak of covet
training in New York became very
difficult to sustain so most of the team
despised the city of New York I I was
the only person in the group that liked
living in New York I think part of the
problem was that uh I was the only one
who actually lived in Manhattan the
others had to commute to New York and
there's a world of difference between
living in New York and commuting to New
York so most of them had a very negative
view of New York City
that was compounded by covid uh when
even the basic Act of training became
very very difficult and uh so everyone
decided they want to leave so there was
a prospect of
a complete breakup between myself and
the team or I would have to leave New
York there was a difficult decision for
me to make as I lived in New York for 30
years
um I had built my life there and had
most of my friends and Associates that I
know here in America New Yorkers
so I thought you know these guys have
been unstained uh incredibly loyal to me
as students so
I should also be loyal to them of course
so I decided that if they wanted to
leave I would go with them we decided uh
to go to Puerto Rico because there was a
a private gym where we could train
through the covert period
um I personally wanted to go to Texas I
thought that Texas was a better place
for the team to go but many of the
students including senior students like
Gordon Ryan Craig Jones had been to
Puerto Rico and stayed with one of the
head officials of ADCC Mo Jason
so uh they loved their experience in
Puerto Rico and uh almost everyone
wanted to go down there
so I tried to explain to him there's a
world of difference between going to a
place for vacation versus living there
but that didn't
have any effect so the decision was made
a majority decision was made to go to
Puerto Rico
um
in Puerto Rico the conditions in which
the team lived changed significantly
when you're in New York New York is such
a big city that if there's any
uh tension between team members and
inevitably there will be in a
competitive sport where everyone's
fighting each other you can kind of bury
them in the size of the city because
there's so many distractions in New York
you know you come and you do your
workout you go outside and it's New York
City
um in Puerto Rico we lived in a very
small uh local Town Dorado and most of
the athletes were living with each other
and so unlike New York where there was
always a break you trained together but
when training was over you went about
your life in New York and New Jersey
um with everyone living in very close
proximity to each other any tensions
got magnified because there was no
relief from them you didn't get to get
away from people if you had a problem
with someone on the mat or now you had
to to live with them for uh the rest of
the day and the night and this goes on
for long periods of time so I believe it
had the effect of magnifying whatever
tensions there were in particular there
was a uh a family tension between two
brothers which magnified over time
um
uh and you know as so often as the case
you get two brothers growing up one
older one younger and the younger one
wants to
grow and uh and feel somewhat like a
young tree underneath a bigger tree and
um uh sometimes people just need their
space so there was there was some
unhappiness and um as a younger brother
I can understand yeah yeah as a little
tree that had to grow up under a bigotry
yeah so um [ __ ] the big tree
there's a lot of aggression I'm sorry
unresolved family issues coming out here
I love you he doesn't he's lying
so uh as time went by these these
tensions started uh increasing they came
to a point where
um it was difficult for them even to be
in the training room together at that
point you're starting to you know when
Once training takes a hit then you
you've got to start to address these
um the attempts at reconciliation
uh fell through and uh
a decision was made to to move to Texas
I wanted everyone to move as a team
what I wanted to do was keep the team
together
as long as the period leading up to 80cc
so that everyone could train together
so I said okay there's problems but
let's just tough it out one year we
moved to Texas
let's just go there and keep Unity if
some people don't want to train with
other people that's fine but I believe
that the team would be weakened by
breaking apart I believe that they had
an excellent Rapport as training
Partners the technical level was
increasing dramatically
many of the younger athletes are really
starting to come into their own and
really develop well and so my take on it
was okay if there's problems
so be it but let's all just stay
together until 80cc 2022 was a unified
team go out prepare yourselves as best
you can and
um uh and then after that we can make a
decision as to whether we break up or
not
um but that was rejected and uh the team
split and um uh they moved to Austin uh
we'd made prior arrangements to go to a
local gym and they took that Gem and we
were left with no gym and more or less
homeless in uh in Austin so uh a year
out from ADCC yes this is one year out
so roughly three quarters of the uh
competitive athletes left in in one week
um so uh at that point uh that was
probably the lowest point because at
that point not only did we not have a
place to train
um we had very few training partners for
the few that had remained
and um uh the main athlete in the team
Gordon Ryan was going through a
particularly bad spell with his
unresolved stomach issues and there was
doubt as to whether or not he could
compete at all and was actively thinking
about retiring from the sport so maybe
not compete ever again potentially yeah
yeah so that was a time when I was like
man this is the whole program seems to
be dead in the water at this point
um most of the competitive athletes were
gone there were very few training
partners for the few that remained and
the main athlete around whom the group
had initially bonded
um was seemingly out of action possibly
permanently
where is your mind what were you
mentally uh my my thinking is
everything bad passes in time I've had a
lot of bad points in my life so um uh my
life experiences whenever things seem
dark
have patience time will ultimately cure
most ills not all of them but most of
them and
um uh I'm confident that if you give me
a new crop of students I can
I can produce magic but it's going to
take time so that conference was a in
part a source of strength yes it's just
like I I wasn't confident that ADCC 2022
would go well because we only had one
year without a gym and with a team that
was completely broken up to um to to
even an attempt to get into ADCC
so um uh things looked a little Grim but
I was confident you know given enough
time I get in a new uh group of students
and work
um as it turns out uh one of
the uh demonstration partners that uh I
used during filming for instructional
videos who lives in Boston uh John Carla
badoni was interested in the idea of
coming down and training but he'd always
felt like it would be difficult because
there were people in his weight class
who were already there and he felt it
would be awkward
um but now that they had left that
opened up an area for him so he was the
first one to come down he moved from
Boston to um uh Austin Texas
I began teaching at a local school it
was rather like going back into my
earliest days in jiu-litsu I went from
teaching at the big henzo Gracie Academy
to a tiny school in Puerto Rico and now
an even smaller School in Austin Texas
and locals would come in and train and I
would watch every day teaching their
twice a day seven days a week and I
would see people come in and train and I
would say this guy has some potential
this guy has some potential and I would
recruit people and bring them to an
another gym where they would train with
the professionals and if they proved
Adept and hardworking and someone who
can work well in a team they would stay
and build their skills as time went by
um more and more such people started
coming in and we had some remarkable
people like a young South African purple
belt Luke Griffith came in he had lost
in the European trials for ADCC and he
was down on his luck he came into Austin
he did a show against the local purple
about and lost again so he was a
uh feeling bad about his performance in
his future and he came in and I thought
he was a lovely kid who worked hard and
trained well
um so he became one of the main training
partners he was similar size to Gordon
so I encouraged him to train with with
Gordon whenever he could
and he more and more people started
coming into the train under that kind of
basis
um one day I got a text from uh Gordon
who was filming an instructional video
in Boston he said hey you know Nicholas
murugali was training at this he was
shooting video at the same time as me
and we we just uh did some grappling
he's a really nice guy and uh he's
literally never trained with without a
game before he's uh for those of you who
don't know Nicholas murugali is a uh one
of the outstanding gee Jiu Jitsu
competitors of his Generation
Um has an amazing uh game and is a
superstar with the uh the ghee side of
the sport but it never even trained
without a ghee once in his life so his
first ever
nogi training session is with Gordon
Ryan the best no geek competitor of all
time and I remember Gordon texting me
saying he's really talented he's a nice
guy and he wants to come down to Texas
and train so yeah sounds great so over
time just more and more people started
coming in and um uh I told everyone like
you guys are at a severe disadvantage
like you're you've got very little time
to get ready for ADCC Luke wasn't even
an ACC had to win trials same for uh Dan
matisoy who he'd failed at trials and
needed to get a win to even get into
ADCC
so around this time a doctor suggested
by uh Moe jasm who had himself had
stomach issues earlier in his life began
working with uh Gordon Ryan and and
Moe's the organizer of ADC yes
he's the uh the head organizer he
was able to get Gordon Ryan not cured
but significantly better than he was
before and
to a level where Gordon could could
train up to five to six days a week
and it was a big Improvement on what was
going on during the end of the time in
Puerto Rico
so things started moving we had a core
group of athletes uh training at a local
gym
which was very very generously offered
to us by uh
the head manager of Roca sunglasses a
company here in Austin Texas they have a
private corporate gym which we were able
to train in
and these talented youngsters from
around the globe essentially came
together and I said you guys are gonna
have to train harder than you've ever
trained in your life because you've got
less time to get ready for this than
anyone and uh you're going to be going
up against people potentially who
know exactly what I teach because I've
been teaching them a lot longer than
I've been teaching you in addition to
the other best people in the world
so it was a uh an incredible challenge
for them and I must say all of them
gave literally everything they had
everything I asked for they gave twice
as much and um we had a crazy training
schedule as many as three classes per
day I know that sounds easy you know
three classes a day right but try doing
it sometime these classes are not your
average classes these are preparation
for 80cc
as they're both mentally and physically
very very hard and um uh we had many
people come in and try to train
alongside us and they fell
off by the side of the road within Days
forget about weeks months or a full year
of this
um
I gave a very abbreviated set of skills
for the athletes I chomped everything
down to what I believed were the the
most essential skills
um uh anything that wasn't essential to
ADCC preparation was just pushed aside
and
um they had to focus almost entirely on
ADCC with one exception I'll come to
that soon
um of the the period of their training
here in Austin so it was
compacted by time and also by
the breadth of skill that I taught
everything was just purely for ADCC
preparation in a very short period of
time uh Dan manisoyo and Luke Griffith
and Oliver tarza all won European trials
and got into ADCC Nicholas miragali was
already a superstar so he was invited
but he had to show himself so we
enrolled him in local
shows here in Austin where he had his
first three uh no game matches
um
and with each match you could see
progress being made and so that
convinced the 80cc people okay he's good
enough to to compete
um he ended up winning decisively a
match against one of the greatest
American Grapplers of all time Raphael
Lovato and this was like a clear sign
that his skill level in nogi was
sufficient to to justify and invite
and by the way Lovato an incredible uh
set of matches in this ADCC yes that was
actually very impressive and retired
yeah
which is a really impressive and
heartbreaking as well but if you go out
that's a good way to go out indeed
so there was this um uh long and tough
preparation and it was compounded by the
fact that it's golden felt better he
felt a need to
build up his own competitive record
prior to ADCC
because he had been inactive for so long
with this stomach issue so he proposed
one of the most ambitious
fight games
that I've ever heard of in grappling
which was he would take on the current
wno champion Pedro Mourinho
who's number one is w owner yeah and
also I believe the current uh no nogi
world champion in IBG if
as a tune-up match as a warm-up match
then he would fight his old nemesis
uh Felipe Pena the only man who
submitted Gordon at black belt and had
defeated Gordon in an 80cc match in
2017.
and then ADCC itself so there was going
to be three big high profile matches
back to back and uh
and very different rule sets so wno was
a 15-minute match uh the fight with
Felipe Pena was no time limit which is a
very different format to compete in and
then ADCC so we had to drag out a
14-week cam covering three matches with
three different rule sets which went and
diametrically opposite directions and
the entire team had to go through all of
this over this 14-week period in
addition to the previous year that they
had been working hard
um there was a further complication in
the midst of all this Nicholas murugali
had to go to the ghee World
Championships and we had to throw an
extra morning class for that to help him
get ready
um Nicholas went on to win the open
weight gold medal in Ziggy competition
and then the next day he had to come
back to Texas and begin his ADCC
preparation it was a crazy crazy time
um but they all came through it so well
I'm I'm immensely proud of what they did
and shockingly in the space of less than
12 months we went from Rock Bottom to
having a more successful 80cc
uh team performance then we did the
previous ADCC
um uh it was in fact the most successful
team performance of the event and as
testimony to how hard those those young
men uh worked in uh in the course of
less than a year to prepare themselves